impossible limb ah [ __ ] you're miss man
that didn't generally okay they're
already gone markiplier box oh no all
right then I guess I'm done
markiplier woke up in a desert in the
dark cold night alone and he needs to go
home
sounds like my life oh alright does not
i'm spaghetti tries again you junior why
to hoody did you like my trick I know
you did
hi I'm alive oh oh one more try gimme
gimme gimme that only mildly hurt oh
[ __ ] my face who's going right for those
alright what have you got for me
what are you got planned how are you
gonna kill me for secret down there haha
winner's circle yes yes please secret
every message is important it is
recommended you Reeve ever Wow okay
Oh PS it's a giant mushroom falling all
right ha whoops yep Thomas me dick I'm
dead how ha oh hello mr. mushroom okay
don't kill me don't fall in the gap ah
oh this is for cryptic and impossible MA
oh you you ass bastard you're just
trying to fool me huh Oh God
to some but oh I'm still alive oh man ah
okay
whoa whoa easy there Sonny Jin ah God
I'm gonna spend the rest of this whole
episode just trying to beat this one
goddamn thing I'm possible Mario site go
under these blocks oh this is made by
Casspi if that wasn't obvious just with
how good the levels made I'm not enough
I didn't wanna oh I'm up here now what
now but I'm doing it I'm doing it to it
oh god why why they called it a
markiplier said with markiplier wrath
why am i angry exactly where do I need
to go oh hello no no no you can't do
this debate ah okay that's why all right
what am I supposed to do
ah don't look good I think I'm just
supposed to die horribly ain't good them
floating M's that's a bad sign
markiplier ballpen guy was open by the
name of this is gonna be a ball pill
where I just have a little bit of fun
you know flail around a little like
[Applause]
Marga blah bought spike right okay there
we go then whoa those are weird but
adorable I think ha OH
mistake no no no no no no no just there
we go okay nice and safe so that we
don't get more marks Construction Co oh
this is going to be horrible but quick
and efficient oh I would never but for
the sake of the game Ohioan city smash
huge fan fellow Ohioan oh I guess I
can't go very far oh hi oh oh you
wounded me miss Meade dickbags come on
Marga Blair's cliff think you can
survive the fall
maybe oh this cliff got steep well
this cliff is wheat wow wow wow wow no
rib cage I can't even Pogo correctly
anymore Wow
face-first into the axis is a
possibility well I made it to the
winner's circle I'm a winner in my own
eyes and my mommy loves me too
oh you bastard goodish there
I got it done they're gonna kill them
all level there's a guard you plate why
are my clothes here my game mana clothes
every time shadow died it's boring I've
already brawl you jerk
okay got blasted there this has been
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye